one month we have ignition we have
lift-off and we have liftoff of Antares
beginning the journey of the G David
Lough Cygnus cargo vehicle to the
International Space Station baby moma
that are seen via Marz ad0 a
all systems on stage born performing
well in the mission
and tired of making a second flight on
this on this mission were sending this
on a first journey of many international
vacation like they fix the rock Hammond
ah looks like beautiful view
propulsion avionics guidance and
steering systems are already well at
this point we're getting a good
downrange video very clear day to fly
out one minute ten seconds since long
nice views of the Eastern Shore and
miles per hour at an altitude of 66
statute miles operation there we see
what appears to be a very nominal
separation of the first stage beautiful
separation there it's a very clean
separation between the upper spec and
stage one stage one is drifting
interesting nicely away from the vehicle
at this point frogs got good current the
first of the upper stack attitude
control systems has been enabled we're
now co stink on a ballistic phase of the
mission until we've reached the proper
conditions for a fairing separation and
then stage to ignition